HE IS NOW COMPARING THE MOVEMENT
TO A CULT.
WE ARE "OUT FRONT" WITH HIS
STORY IN TONIGHT'S INSIDE LOOK.
>> JANUARY 6th, 2021, IT WAS
GREATEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
>> WHY?
>> I FELT LIKE A PATRIOT THAT
WAS STANDING BESIDE OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS, SPEAKING UP AGAINST
KING GEORGE.
I FELT LIKE BRAVEHEART.
>> WE FIRST MET HIM AT A RALLY
ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF JANUARY
6th.
AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION, HE
LIVED IN HIS CAR AND WENT TO
EVERY STOP THE STEAL RALLY.
NOW HE IS CALLING THE MOVEMENT A
CULT, IT IS MESSY.
>> IF SOMETHING WAS POSTED
SAYING THAT THERE IS A RALLY,
LIKE I WAS NOT IN CONTROL.
I WAS GOING, NO MATTER WHAT.
HOW DO I GET CAUGHT UP IN THIS?
I HAVE NEVER BEEN TO A TRUMP
RALLY.
YOU KNOW, I WASN'T ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: THIS INTERVIEW
JANUARY 6th, WE HAD THE SAME
QUESTION.
HOW DID SO MANY PEOPLE GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY WERE WILLING TO
COMMIT CRIMES TO STOP A
DEMOCRATIC ELECTION, ALL WHILE
CALLING THEMSELVES PATRIOTS.
>> THEY PUSHED ME OUT.
>> Reporter: SO WE SPENT FOUR
HOURS LISTENING TO EVERY DETAIL
OF KEITH'S POLITICAL JOURNEY.
>> AT THE TIME I LIVED IN
GEORGIA.
I GET THERE ON ELECTION DAY AND
THERE WERE ALREADY A COUPLE CARS
IN THE PARKING LOT.
A RECORD TURNOUT THAT THEY SAY
THAT THERE WAS IN FULTON COUNTY,
GEORGIA, WHICH IS THE COUNTY I
VOTED IN, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> WASN'T THERE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF EARLY VOTING?
>> IN THAT DEMOGRAPHIC, IT'S A
POOR AREA.
IT'S PREDOMINANTLY A BLACK AREA.
YOU WILL NEVER BE ABLE CONVINCE
ME THEY WERE SITTING AROUND
WATCHING CNN AND FOX NEWS AND
ALL THESE THINGS AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY WERE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT
WAS THE ELECTION AND GETTING
THEIR BALLOT IN.
IF YOU ASK PEOPLE, IS JOE BIDEN
GOING TO GET MORE OF THE BLACK
VOTE THAN BARACK OBAMA?
PEOPLE WOULD SAY NO AND BIND
SUPPOSEDLY DID.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> RIGHT, BUT THE PICTURE IS ONE
I'M INTERESTED IN, WHICH IS,
THAT YOU HAVE SKEPTICISM ABOUT
THE BLACK VOTE IN THIS ELECTION.
WHY IS I.T. SEEMS TO ME YOU SAID
YOU LIVED IN A BLACK AREA AND
HALF OF THOSE PEOPLE DIDN'T PAY
ATTENTION TO THE ELECTION.
WHY DID YOU THINK YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
AND BLACK PEOPLE WOULDN'T?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT EVERYONE
IS INTERESTED IN POLITICS LIKE I
AM.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT
RACIAL LINES.
>> Reporter: TRUMP.
HAS REPEATED THIS SAME TROPE.
IT'S NOT FACT.
IN 2008 AN ESTIMATED 95% OF
BLACK VOTERS VOTED FOR OBAMA F.
2020, 92% FOR BIDEN.
THIS WAS REPEATED UNTIL IT SEEMS
LIKE COLD HARD TRUTH AS HE WENT
FROM PROTEST TO PROTEST IN STOP
THE STEAL GROUP.
I'M NOT LIKE TRYING TO SAY ARE
YOU A BAD PERSON OR LIKE YOU
WOULD USE A RACIAL SLUR.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AT IS YOU
MIGHT NOT BE SENSITIVE TO THE
BIG PICTURE ABOUT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE DISPUTING VOTES ONLY IN
PLACES WHERE MOST OF THE VOTERS
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR MIGHT TAKE SOME
OFFENSE TO THAT.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT STOP THE
STEAL WAS ABOUT.
>> STOP THE STEAM WAS THE ABOUT
THOSE VOTES DON'T COUNT?
SOME OF THOSE VOTES DON'T COUNT,
NOT YOUR VOTE, BUT SOMEONE
ELSE'S.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BE PAINTED
INTO THIS NARRATIVE THAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO GO DOWN THIS RABBIT
HOLE.
I'M KIND OF DONE WITH THE RACIAL
PART OF THIS.
>> THIS IS THE PARTY OF TRUMP.
>> I GOT INTRODUCED TO ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
THAT WEEK IN GEORGIA.
I REMEMBER ALEX JONES BEING
THERE, ELLY ALEXANDER, THE
FOUNDER OF STOP THE STEAM.
I MET THE LEADER OF THE PROUD
BOYS, HE WAS REALLY NICE.
HE'S NOT A REALLY BIG GUY.
HE'S A LITTLE BIGGER THAN ME.
>> HERE'S WHAT'S INTERESTING, IS
THAT LIKE THESE SMALL GROUPS WHO
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ON THE FRINGE
SEE A MASS MOVEMENT.
>> YES.
100%.
>> TONIGHT BRIGG CROWD IS GOING
WILD.
>> THE MEN WAS GROWING.
>> THERE IS MOUNTAINS OF
EVIDENCE, THIS ELECTION WAS A
FRAUD ON AMERICA.
>> SYDNEY POWELL COMES OUT.
EVERYBODY FELL LIKE SHE IS THE
ONE THAT IS GOING TO UNVEIL ALL
THE EVIDENCE, ELECTION FRAUD.
BUT THE PEOPLE THAT WERE GIVING
EVIDENCE OF ELECTION FRAUD IS
THE SAME MESSAGE WE HAD HEARD A
DAY BEFORE, WEEKS BEFORE, BUT IT
WAS LIKE IT'S COMING.
IT'S GOING TO BE REVEALED.
LIKE KEEPING US, KEEPING US
HOLDING ON FOR THE NEXT BREATH.
>> ALL THAT ENERGIES WITH
RELEASED, JANUARY 6th.
HE SAW WHAT WE SAW.
HE DIDN'T TAKE THE SAME LESSON.
>> I FELT LIKE A PROUD PATRIOT
ON THAT DAY.
IT'S NOT POPULAR TO SAY, BUT
THAT'S WHAT I FELT LIKE.
THEN JUST SOME CRAZY FIGHT
SCENES STARTED HAPPENING.
>> DID YOU THINK ARE WE THE BAD
GUYS?
>> I THOUGHT THIS DOESN'T END
WELL.
>> WHAT MADE YOU REALIZE THIS
WAS A CULT?
THIS IS DEEPLY IMMORAL BEHAVIOR.
IT IS NOT PATRIOTIC EITHER.
>> SO AFTER JANUARY THE 6th, I
CAME HERE, I KEPT MUMBLING, I
FELT LIKE I JUST GOT OUT OF THE
A CULT.
>> WHAT MAKES HIM FRUSTRATED IS
THAT THOUGH HE CALLS IT A CULT,
HE STILL BELIEVES MUCH OF THE
CULT'S PROPAGANDA AND STILL
EXCUSES ITS ACTIONS.
BECAUSE OUR CREW WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE VIOLENCE, IT'S
HARD NOT TO HAVE KEITH SAY IT'S
ASSOCIATION AND IT WAS WRONG.
WHICH ISN'T FAIR, NO ONE WITH
POWER SAID THEY WERE SORRY.
>> IT WAS A LOT OF SELF ANALYSIS
TO GET OVER THE TRAUMA OF
JANUARY 6th, ITSELF, AND THE
THINGS I SAW ON BOTH SIDES.
>> I DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
CAN PICK SIDES, IT SEEMS LIKE A
REALLY CLEAR SIDE.
>> THE THINGS THAT I SAW WERE
BAD REGARDLESS OF WHICH SIDE ARE
YOU ON IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
THERE IS NOTHING ILLEGAL WATCH
AC FIGHT THAT'S HAPPENING.
THAT'S NOT ILLEGAL.
>> A MOB STORMING THE CAPITOL.
IN SOME SENSE IT IS ILLEGAL.
IT'S IMMORAL.
>> BUT I WASN'T DOING ANYTHING
WRONG.
>> YOU WERE A PART OF THE CROWD.
YOUR VERY PRESENCE WAS GIVING
THEM SUPPORT.
>> YOU'RE A PART OF THE CROWD AS
WELL.
>> I WAS A JUNALIST.
>> I WAS A CITIZEN THERE I THINK
WE ARE GETTING SIDE TRACKED.
>> I THINK ACTUALLY THIS IS AT
THE HEART OF THE QUESTION.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM OF A MOP.
IT AB SOLVES PEOPLE OF THEIR
MORAL CULPABILITY THERE.
I WAS JUST ONE PERSON ESPECIALLY
WANT TO BE CLEAR THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY HAD YOU KNOW PHYSICAL
CONFRONTATIONS WITH POLICE
OFFICERS, THEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
>> DO YOU THINK THE LEADERS WHO
MADE THESE PROMISES, THAT THEY
COULDN'T KEEP, THAT THERE WOULD
BE EVIDENCE THAT WOULD CHANGE
THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION, DO
YOU THINK THEY BEAR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE MOB THAT
STORMED THE CAPITOL?
>> NO, I DON'T.
THEY COULD HAVE A GRASS ROOTS
MOVEMENT, STOP THE STEAM.
I REALIZE I HAD BEEN ADDICT TO
THE POLITICS.
I CREATED THIS REFERENCE FOR THE
LEADERS OF STOP THE STEAL.
I FELT I WAS WHICH IS MORE THAN
IRONIC LOOKING BACK, I CAN
PREVENT A SECOND CIVIL WAR.
>> Reporter: HE IS WRITING A
BOOK THAT HE SAYS PEOPLE GOT
ADDICTED TO TRUMP THE WAY HE
DID.
WE FOLLOWED HIM AROUND TO SEE IF
HE CAN GET THROUGH.
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T REMEMBER ME
I SAW YOU SEVERALR SEVERAL TIMES
LAST YEAR.
RIGHT NOW EIGHTH DRUG, I WILL
GET A PATRIOTIC TEE-SHIRT.
>> Reporter: HE WAS NERVOUS HE'D
GET YELLED AT AND THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> I WAS AT THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6th AND MY BOOK IS ABOUT
ALL THE STUFF THAT I SAW AT STOP
THE STEAL RALLY, THEN HOW.
>> DID YOU CHECK WITH THE FBI?
>> NOT YET.
>> YOU PLEAD THE FIFTH.
>> BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
>> I GET THAT A LOT.
THAT IS DISGUSTING.
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR BOOK
AND I PREFER TO YOU GO AWAY.
>> Reporter: HOW'D THAT GO?
>> WOW.
>> ARE THEY IN THE CULT IN.
>> SO, FIRST OF ALL, JUST THEIR
DEMEANOR AND THE WAY THAT BY MY
FLAG AND BY CNN, HOW THEY WERE
JUST COMPLETELY TRIGGERED.
I GUESS I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING TO
TAKE INCOMING FIRE FROM BOTH
SIDES AS THE MARKETING
CONTINUES.
>> AND YOU JUST SWITCHED FROM
THE CULT TO BEING A REFERENCE.
>> I'M LOSING MONEY BY DOING
THIS, HONESTLY, I K CAN HAVE A
GREAT BUSINESS CAREER.
I AM NOT OUT HERE TRYING TO MAKE
A BUNCH OF MONEY F. I MAKE
MONEY, THAT'S COOL.
>> IF YOU ARE NOT HERE NO MAKE A
POLITICAL POINT.
WHAT'S YOUR POINT A AT ALL?
>> MY POINT, I'M DOCK THIS TO
WATCH AUTO FOR PEOPLE.
I HAVE PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR
JOB BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO
GO TO THE RALLY NO MATTER WHAT.
PEOPLE THAT WERE ESTRANGED FROM
THEIR FAMILY, WHETHER IT'S